ضيفي من عمان الخبيه العسكري والاستراتيجي
اللواء فايز الدويري اذا الدكتور فايز
مره اخرى طائرات مسيره تتوجه لتضرب القرم
ما تفسير هذه الخطوه وتكلفتها اذا ما
قرناها كما ذكر قبل قليل الزميل محمود في
المره الماضيه عندما استهد تم استهداف جسر
كرش كانت التكلفه عاليه من خلال رد الفعل
الروسي ما تفسير هذا الهجوم في هذا
التوقيت
يعني عندما تم استهداف جسر كيرش جسر كرش
ورمزيه
ومنذ بدايه القرن الماضي والتفكير في بناء
الجسر كانت قائمه
والجسر كان يغني عن
الممر الرئيسي
الذي يمر من خرسون باتجاه الشرق عوض طرق
الامداد
والمتابع كان يلاحظ ان كافه التعزيزات
لمناطق القتال كانت تاتي من القرن القرم
ليس مستودع لكل شيء انما كانت محطه تستقبل
القادم من روسيا فكان استهداف جسر كرش له
رمزيته وله دلالاته وانعكاساته على
المعركه لكن هناك العديد من المرات التي
تم استهداف ميناسفا ستوبل وغيرها وكانت
الردود عاديه متوقعه اطلاق ثلاثين الى
خمسين الى بعض الحالات الى 60 صاروخ على
البنى التحتيه الان اذا ربطنا ذلك
بتصريحات نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الرئيس
السابق
القيامه لن تقوم حتى لو تم استهدافها
لاكثر من مره هو يمثل اللغه
الخشبيه اذا جاز التعبير في تصدير
التصريحات من
اظهار قدره الردع الروسيه بينما الرئيس
بوتين يمثل الكلام الناعم المغلف
بالدبلوماسيه دعني اقول ان كل ما اتيح
الفرصه
لاوكرانيا ان تستهدف القرن ستستهدفها حتى
وان لم تحدث اضرارا لماذا حتى تبقي كلمه
القرم موجوده ضمن الاراضي الاوكرانيه التي
اعترف بها بعد انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي
لهذا السبب سيتم قصف فكلما اوتيح المجال
والردود لن تكون بالمستوى الذي تم بعد
استهداف جسر كرش من خلال متابعاتك
الميدانيه لما يجري في باغموت اللواء
فايز هل بات الحسم طبعا لصالح الجانب
الروسي قريبه من خلال التقدم لميليشيات
يعني الاجابه او اعطاء وقت بالضبط غير
ممكن لكن هناك نقطه جوهريه
وتحول دراماتيكي في الموقف الاوكراني
عندما تم ايكال مهمه اتخاذ القرار حول
معركه باخموت الى القاضي العسكريين في
البدايه
الرئيسكي كان رفض ورفض النصائح الغربيه
الامريكيه والبريطانيه وقال لا يمكن
التخلي عنود لكن في بعض الحالات تصبح
المعادله خاسره لانه لغه المنطق ستسقط
عاجلا ام اجلا لكن توقيت السقوط يعتمد على
مرتكزات كثيره جدا وبالتالي حجم التضحيه
المقدم من اجل الاحتفاظ بها سيكون في بعض
الحالات مكلف اكثر من اهميه هذه المدينه
لماذا اقول ذلك بعد سته اشهر من القتال لا
اعتقد ان القائد
العسكري الاوكراني لا يدرك الحقيقه بان
باخموت ستسقط اذا ما هو ما هي الخطه
البديله ما هي الخطه باكرا الخطه باء وجهه
نظري هي تعزيز الدفاعات امام
كراماتورسك سلافيا نسك حتى لا يكون سقوط
باخمت يفضي الى سقوط تلك المدن الرئيسيه
من عمان قبل العسكري والاستراتيجيه اللواء
فايز الدويري شكرا جزيلا لك